how's it going bros my name is Pierre
and welcome to fry on a Friday hey what
do you want what can I say it's
practically a miracle so today I am
going to react for your breasts to my
old old old old old old old videos first
off is the minecraft multiplayer fun
video I like how my life was different
back then oh yeah we trap the zombie in
this fort and then we open up and we
just see the zombie sitting in a
minecart was pretty funny good times so
this wasn't actually my first video I
know a lot of people are like whose
first video was Minecraft why let me
play minecraft before when I started off
almost four years ago commentating
wasn't as popular as it is today and for
me to sit alone in a room which I'm
doing right now and and and talking it
was the weirdest thing ever to me oh god
I love how I still have have appear to
Pat that's literally the only thing that
I can destroy it's so creepy more
session destroy' sorry and as you can
see I'm trying out the theater mode and
the theater mode is really awesome
uh-huh so interesting so far I'm so
great by it with a seat in monomorphic
too so I wanted I liked how much thicker
my accent is as well to be one of the
cool kids amazing this is my when I got
100 subs and yeah today we're gonna
celebrate cuz I have 100 subscribers for
y'all
[Music]
okay I shouldn't do sound effects but
anyway I'm already starting to open up
more I seriously want to take my diary
and smother it on the screen with my
hands what the [ __ ] was that I wouldn't
wear I would wear gloves though cuz it's
kind of disgusting to have [ __ ] alright
that makes it less and I don't do this
because I want to be famous
that's the main thing I wanted to do the
only reason why I do this is because
it's fun and you guys are the biggest
part of that night it's because of you
guys that this actually is fun and
that's why I make videos and that's
that's thank you guys again so much I'm
gonna leave two links in description and
open them and that's cute and left some
chill song probably that's adorable
that's my thank you just some [ __ ]
check
that's that's the world wall so cute oh
my god this is so weird to go back to so
while I was doing these Call of Duty
stuff I think I had around like a
hundred 200 subscribers no one really
cared about my videos that much and at
this point the horror game I'm Nisha
came out and at this point I had never
played a horror game I could barely
watch a horror movie and I was like I if
I gotta play it I might as well record
it and I got some pretty good reactions
out of it like this one
and then I uploaded the part 1 of
amnesia and for the first time like
people actually asked for more videos
that had never happened before I kept
doing these montages of me bit getting
scared and those I think those is what
really brought in the bigger audiences I
think by the end of look here's a video
I never uploaded look how cute I am it's
an important video it's a big people to
watch it as possible clip I don't want
it oh god I look so cute back then what
happened
[ __ ] I'm wearing a little scarf [ __ ]
hipster so I was studying at the time it
it was hard to catch up with with school
than making videos and in the summer and
I'm it might say and these are personal
videos that I sent to her I think yeah
I'm not gonna show these these are these
are private but we used to send videos
to each other and oh my god I look so
tiny after this summer I got my
partnership which meant I could actually
get money for making these videos and
after that I started to take it more
seriously and I became more consistent
with my videos I went to visit mutts
yeah look so sexy I'm again it's the
first time I met her yeah oh I miss it
for First Fridays with PewDiePie my
first going everyone my name is Pierre
BAP I've been growing a lot on YouTube
lately and it's a it's great of course
but it's also shameful because I can't
really communicate that the same thing
that it's strict I remember I used to
answer to every single message that I
got now I just have so many like and it
saddens me a lot that I can't do that
anymore that's a pretty cool way to
support me and your chest hair back then
god damnit life was so much easier back
then I kept doing the horror games but I
realized that the [ __ ]
we're running out like there weren't a
lot of new horror games coming out like
they are today they're always coming at
new horror games so I realized I'm gonna
have to start making different type of
videos or I'm not gonna have any content
at all to cover so I started doing happy
wheel and funny enough people were like
what the [ __ ] are you doing
how [ __ ] dare you play non horror
stuff and and like and people are saying
I copy other youtubers and all that
stuff people were very negative about me
playing happy wheels but I was like it's
it's fun I want to do what's fun I don't
want to be forced to keep playing horror
games just because that's what people
want and happy wheels turn out to be one
of my most successful series ever so
it's hard sometimes you have to listen
to bruschettas and sometimes the your
you might be better off not not to do it
oh yeah and I started making videos with
cry I asked cries so early if he wanted
to make a video with me and then I think
after like 2 months he was like hell
yeah let's do it so we played a cry of
free air with support I wouldn't I want
to see that video
alright cry why you're so handsome
thank you can you change your here's the
guy you thought I was gonna be the beer
belly
exactement
that's good times man good times but
yeah that's a little journey through how
I got started on YouTube and that's
that's how it all went down I want to
take this time to just fully say thank
you to you bros who are watching my
videos and showing your support every
day and it means literally the world to
me and especially your brothers who've
been through with me for years now
that's just insane to me that you guys
have kept out for so long I think that's
that's so cool and and and really thank
you so much for doing that it's good to
have you with me and I hope we can do
this for a for a while longer at least
so thank you for leaving like and here's
an awesome breakfast for